on the show we've had several
conversations about masculinity but tell
us like through this journey and
previous journeys how's your journey as
a as a white
cisgendered you know
uh male
how has it uh
evolved over the years it's interesting
i mean i grew up very much i was an
athlete you know i
uh
i
grew up in a working class family so i
had all the messaging of uh of
conventional in the 70s and 80s
masculinity and you know uh
conventional like
uh cis
relationships
um and
i always felt you know uh i don't know i
didn't fit well into that
that exact paradigm
which is first what led me i think to
become a theater actor um
and and sort of explore like why does my
little conservative town feel so strange
everyone's very nice by and large
with there's a lot of great values here
but then at the same time once i got out
into the world and i said oh okay but
it's a calcified
super
conservative like white christian town
and so long ago they are they
established no people of color
no
people that aren't straight etc and so
on
and so
it kind of took me by surprise
eventually when i started getting
any visibility uh as an actor and i got
accused uh pretty quickly of being
masculine
um or sometimes even macho
and i was like wow dad
where are you getting that i think it's
the voice nick
well it's the voice it's the mustache
when i have it at the plant i am i
understand in hindsight but but what it
pointed out immediately was how
superficial that estimation was